the roe v wade reversal that has
hollywood fired up from last night's
awards to the streets where full house's
jody sweetin got knocked to the ground
jody telling me what led up to that
shocking moment
what actually happened that caused that
confrontation the confrontation had
already been happening it was such a
crazy day and there was so much
happening i was walking forward and
one of the officers grabbed the handle
on the back of my backpack and threw me
down
the video shows two officers in full
tactical gear pushed the actress to the
ground fellow protesters helped jodi get
back on her feet you know protests can
be inconvenient they can be loud and
they can they involve a lot of people
and
that is our first amendment right and
one of the great things about this
country and so as long as we can
exercise that i will continue to do so
so i do want to let you know what the
lapd said to us in a statement they said
the lapd is aware of a video clip of a
woman being pushed to the ground by
officers not allowing the group to enter
on foot and overtake the 101 freeway the
force used will be evaluated against the
lapd's policy and procedure thoughts
i mean they can review policy they can
do something i'm not pressing any
charges i think the most important thing
is for people to realize what's going on
to continue to use their voices what
makes you especially passionate about
the overturning of roe v wade i have two
daughters they are 14 and nearly 12. and
to know that the rights and choices of
my daughters could be vastly different
if i lived several hundred miles in
another direction is terrifying while
jody took to the streets to protest the
ruling other celebrities rita moreno
cheryl burke and ireland baldwin shared
their own experiences to raise awareness
i was raped when i was a teenager
and i was completely unconscious when it
happened the only person who knew was a
nurse that treated me shortly after
ireland who's the daughter of alec
baldwin and kim bazinger says she had an
abortion years later when she was in an
unhappy relationship i chose to get an
abortion because i know exactly what it
felt like to be born between two people
who hated each other
the late paul walker's daughter 23 year
old meadow walker revealed she had an
abortion in 2020 during the pandemic
quote i was lucky enough to have a great
doctor who supported me through the
debilitating process
at the bet awards last night the show's
in memoriam segment mourned the end of
roe v wade
lizzo who opened the show also made a
powerful statement thank you lizzo for
pledging one million dollars to planned
parenthood
[Music]
you